it's the day after Easter which means
people probably have a lot of painted
hard-boiled eggs lying around the house
yes
that always happens the Monday after
Easter that's why today is a big deal
for one of our show's sponsors they run
their entire campaign just one day a
year once again they've asked Andy and I
to be their spokespeople I'm gonna be
honest we don't love doing these ads but
these guys pay a fortune so let's get
this over with the following message is
paid for by the egg salad Council of
California
egg salad it's the quiet salad Hey egg
salad the other use for your ice cream
scoop eggs egg salad if the top is brown
just stick down egg
egg salad ninety eight trillion
Salmonella bacteria you can't be wrong
egg salad the perfect place to hide
grandpa's pills
egg salad
it's like caulking for your stomach
egg egg salad it's like a nursing home
became a food egg salad doesn't look
like eggs doesn't smell like salad hey
egg salad when you're the last in the
group to order lunch and you panic hey
egg salad
we guarantee no bullies will take your
lunch egg salad voted number one salad
by hospice workers hey
egg salad the official food have I give
up
egg egg salad it's the fart you can eat
[Music]
this sketch won't end please make it
stop
hey what did we do to deserve this hell
8 I don't know how much longer I can
hold up these stinky sandwiches just
announced a guest or something it's your
job from the Emmy award-winning HBO
series Game of Thrones
Isaac Hempstead Wright is here
[Applause]